hey I was gonna breasts - paper this is
what happened last episode oh my god
that [ __ ] I hate her
they got [ __ ] Jesus Christ excited to
welcome all my pals back to the annual
Blackwood winter getaway sounds very
excited I'm so excited I'm everyone of
you and just to share some moments that
we'll never forget for the sake of my
sister's I need to go find Sam yeah
she's a [ __ ] and next to Josh that's
how we met
boom butterfly effect
okay that's a weird way to end it man I
feel like this mountain gets bigger
every time I climb it oh yeah right
oh my god it's so awkward and they do
that
Josh Hannah and best brother I'm
starting to learn the names or like
their relationships complex thoughtful
and loving I just want to kiss him what
I'm straight some very convincing inside
way I'm getting withdrawals already you
got a spare million lying around I'll
fix you right up
we should just we should just count the
cliches no phone signal
oh my god so in tucking in it
and breathing heavily another horror
cliche yeah man so should we gossip or
should we worry
I would worry a little bit I wanted to
be have a softer side and I just want us
to have a good time you know
like we always used to okay
damn it freakin thing what else maybe
there's another way in there are a
million ways in there just all locked
it's gonna be like a window around the
corner we can get like get open or
something waiting are you saying we
should break in I don't think it's
technically breaking in if you own the
place right hey not if I don't report
you lead the way Cochise laughs [ __ ]
this character is so weird I don't trust
that guy my god she looked like she
would sell like her own craft and [ __ ]
weird to be back it's nice to be back so
good but a little cold I think I could
use some time crawled up by the fire
that does sound pretty nice oh my god
well she wants to curl up in the fire
don't [ __ ] alright let's follow this man
the brother so I set up so I'm playing
on my computer screen
it's pretty nice I don't know how
console players yes you did look pretty
odd today am i right ladies up top play
on a TV it's awful
compared to this computer sitting close
to it I don't know
sleeper hit kind of gal you know and I
just want to rip that Parker right off
of her and make some snow angels am i
right yeah I'm all right
I just want to take a taters and just
shove my face in them am i right huh
just want to take a butt cheek and just
put my notes in there and do a good
smell am i right ha ha am I right ha ha
just want to take a dump on her chest am
i right sorry cut it out man now I'm
just gonna be a boy yeah yeah the bone
zone the [ __ ] how old are these guys me
it is yeah but we're like friends listen
dude look around you look at these
beautiful mountains do you see any
parents I mean can you imagine a more
perfect ripe scenario just dripping with
erotic possibilities you and Ashlee
alone Atlantic in here and all the
groundwork you've been a perfect
gentleman now you come in for the kill I
kind of agree with that so how old are
they supposed to be if we talked about
no parents I'm gonna agree with this by
the way don't worry and like what kind
of parents lets them back to place where
they [ __ ] sister died like my right
ladies
sorry man I look good in this outfit
this is pretty worried about it bro
don't worry about it bro ski
using their buns off and last time I
checked that's not a good way to get
laid
hey what if they want to get close I
like cool buns like it when they're cold
it's nice to put your hand on him what
okay so here we go we can use this
perhaps I think yes we found a clue
outside
I might actually use it cool it on the
phone top what why it's pretty much how
you talk about well you know I mean I
could do all this stuff well you got an
app they can get us into the lodge nope
got an app that can get you laid
actually I knew it you don't okay
there's an app for that
all right so there's no acts that's a
bit on you I guess
oh yeah I also set up so I have
headphones it was a painting they asked
for some reason to set that up with the
TV that's why I switched it gives me
more of a all right you bro should
should watch this with headphones to
promise I won't scream too much that
snow is just glued to the [ __ ] thing
there you go babbling babbling
how will we get that window open that
seriously smooth at a climbing class you
mean Jim yeah you know what oh my god I
don't think so
they're here then what is this
creepy whoa Chris I just got an awesome
idea yeah totally
what is it okay so I'm pretty sure that
I've got some deodorant in one of the
bathrooms you could use that with the
lighter
I don't follow house it has a stick of
deodorant gonna help spray on it's a can
oh yeah now I got you now we can heat up
the buns
yup ones we melted just point to spray
can in the lighter bye bye frozen lock
bingo all right so you got this I'm
gonna go sort something out you up for
hunting around in the dark for a little
bit no what in the actual [ __ ] are they
talking about I cannot relate to these
people whatsoever but here I am playing
a game with them that's cool all right
well let's find that deodorant I thought
he was gonna say I was smelly first a
little bit of funding Oh a totem how
convenient mister totten let's look at
you okay we see that there might be a
fire in here unless we [ __ ] at a buck up
it's very interesting I can't honestly
like this kind of game I can't wait to
just [ __ ] try out again right oh god
what was that
right after we played it hello so rat
here there must be a rat there's no way
that Indian massacre guy is here am i
right
snowboard we're now where we sat
deodorant
something here hmm a memento perhaps
let's take a look ex janitor comes
victim here for arson swears to revenge
well that's probably not a great thing
all right I have a good feeling that
there will be deodorant over yeah yes
deodorant where are you come here Geo
Trent this is so [ __ ] creepy Jesus
Christ did not expect this [ __ ] this is
that the family photo let's look at it
huh that's cool his dad looked like that
porringer sorry that is actually cool
there she is the dead one that's creepy
they all look like actual people I gotta
give them credit for that usually the
game character just doesn't look like
they look like game characters but they
look like people in this game it's cool
how was it that was probably the devil
coming to eat your buns okay this way
nope all right well then this way yes
yes that's of course yeah yes said - yo
Trent
this is kind of creepy for the first
time hello deodorant yo Trent oh I
definitely hear something
what is that creepy damn it it's locked
huh way to spy on the girls yes all
right we got this sorry I was just
looking for the deodorant deodorant no
no I swear I hear something here and
it's bothering me okay we're very close
to duty or in I can smell it
hey you want children this is where we
came from my bad my bad
let's go back no big deal everyone makes
mistakes in life
no one does flawless playthroughs unless
maybe you do speedruns okay I there's
definitely someone in here come on why
do I even try okay there's something
here I need to check it out all right
what do we get no electricity great this
place is so [ __ ] creepy at least a
guy can like prep a little bit for if
it's such an important party am i right
ladies I think we need to go upstairs
right now
damn [ __ ] awesome pillow though
although I'd probably sell it they left
a window open if my sister might like
daughters diner shadow it's weird to
think about I don't have any daughters
all right let's close this is bothering
me I can't oh my god god damn it I'm so
bothered by this and who would have
thought a hunt for some deodorant would
be this difficult how did that plant
survive for an entire year in the cold
you know what I'm not gonna ask oh oh oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] statues it's creepy
come on come on and the camera angle
work is a little awkward I would say
it's a little weird it reminds me of old
school horror games which is probably a
good thing I'm just like I just really
need that deodorant man it's my life my
life my life depends on it
all right all right no we came from here
god [ __ ] damn it must be in here
let's follow the devil thing yes this
must be it great
hopefully nothing scary spooky
I smell a jump scare oh it's it's a
dirty one it's coming brace yourself
bros yep tension is building it's gonna
happen ah it's the deodorant
I hope there's nothing inside a
hamburger oh there it is let me grab ah
I knew it
son of a jump-scare come on man
that was so obvious but so damn loud
all right we got the deal right
they are freezing their buns well I can
heat those buns up now latest Miletus
step right back don't worry about me I'm
just do Duran renting he's seriously
touched it what a [ __ ] idiot
do you mean right tiger yeah like I
definitely does drugs
ah we're all here awesome
still this place barely looks any
different and nobody's been up here even
with all the police coming in and out
not a lot of action up here lately
ya know yeah I'm pissed
you stopped up at home bro will do yeah
come on in take a load off that whatever
you want
you just think whatever you want anymore
right oh [ __ ] oh boy
all right um I don't like when people
threaten and stuff be better stay away
from my girl bro yeah you better back
off she's mine bro like that's stupid
so I'm just gonna be upfront with him
what the hell were you doing with him
out on the trail yeah what I saw UNM the
telesco that's kind of weird before we
just ran into each other been a while so
we hug and I said hello
that gets long um I wouldn't apologize
but I wouldn't like threatened him
either
I don't like any of these options to be
honest all right since he seems so
threatened I'll just go with like the
character that he's going win and I
think this is the most appropriate right
right I'm sure it's all it was you can
think whatever you want it's a free
country
watch yourself Mike
alright that works I'm happy with that
that girl is so horny Jesus Christ that
girl is such a [ __ ] Jesus Christ she's
definitely gonna die no one wants in on
your territory honey excuse me did you
say something oh did you not hear me
with your sluttiness - hey someone's
bitter she didn't make the cut all a big
cattle call with that dreamboat Congrats
you're Top Cow that's real deep calling
miss homecoming a cow oh my god I'm
liking the decision here all right chill
out Emily that's uncalled for
I feel like come on we just started a
party in there already fighting like
calling each other [ __ ] what kind of
[ __ ] friends are these let's just
chill out all right oh my god oh you're
the only one who could put him down no
one else can play with your toys you're
such a [ __ ] whatever I don't give a
crap what you think at least I can think
four-point-oh [ __ ] on a roll suck on
that one it's four point oh good all the
natural advantages you can handle you
couldn't buy a moldy loaf of bread with
your skanky ass are you serious [ __ ] um
well I didn't really work last time but
I'm stop please
Emily stop this is out of hand there's
no reason to fight like this oh yeah and
why you picking fights over your
ex-boyfriend huh stop it
this is not why we came up here this is
not helping it's not what I wanted
it's not what I wanted we can't get
along for ten minutes and maybe we need
a little bit of a break right Mike why
don't you check out the guest cabin and
when I told you about yeah any place
without that oh [ __ ] it's right up the
trail
that's over yeah so Josh uh you'll get
this fire going where's my bag huh my
god a little bag with the pink pattern
the one I got on Rodeo Matt are you are
you listening oh my god don't you
remember next to the Italian shoe place
where I got the stilettos and you
knocked over the rack while you were
drooling all over that girl at the
counter well I mean she was asking about
my letter chair right because she gave a
[ __ ] about your designer leather jacket
why do you hate my jacket Matt I need my
bag oh my god m-maybe you just forgot it
do you seriously think I'd forget my bag
whoa you must have left it down by the
cable car
come on hon we'll be back soon then we
can get warm you can get very warm not
with her she's so unattractive okay poor
guy
but they aren't ugly babies - that
sounded a little racist I'm so sorry
okay what's with her [ __ ] backpack
she's gonna take a bath they don't have
electricity she's gonna take a bath kind
of party is this
I'm so confused this cabin is the
coziest the most romantic love den you
will ever lay our eyes upon if we ever
make it feelin looks on our side
play your cards right and maybe you will
get lucky hey porn stars gonna need
these porn star I'd pay to see it uh
gross hey I'm sorry to kick you out like
that or isn't it oh I'm sure you'll find
a way to entertain yourselves you have
fun with the peanut gallery
oh I almost forgot you gotta fire up the
generator so you can see where you're
going
it's a park out there all right Roger
that I was flirting with me okay with us
wait really what that's the bad kind of
threesome
it's the uncool kind of threesome all
right so well depending on who you are I
don't care okay great
we're gonna fire up the generator or is
he gonna do it and this place is cold
what controls are inverted there we go
that's [ __ ] heavy rain all over again
why are we stopping here
what why Oh God
look at her face uh do a duck face do it
do it okay oh god it seems the guy from
[ __ ] yeah perfect
we're like the cutest couple
you should be modeled you keep that
camera handy and maybe I'll let you
start my portfolio
and these guys just [ __ ] already noted
Jesus Christ [ __ ] bunch of bunnies
Jesus my god every sentence every
sentence is about sex and who says the
birth out what is this yep kind of a
bummer that's exactly what I was gonna
say alright let's just get the
electricity going so these guys can [ __ ]
it out
all right he's got a good bow tie that
border he wants our voting give him the
bull with it she can cut in on what we
got going on maybe if we're lucky he'll
try and follow us out of here and get
eaten by a bear
she was kind of being a [ __ ] I think
you bring out the worst she better she's
such a [ __ ] she better suck on a dick
big fat [ __ ] it wasn't that wasn't that
what we're yeah we're checking out the
cab and I Jimmy just makes sense that
you get the electricity go in first but
hey maybe I'm crazy is it a totem okay
cool
this means we might see something in my
god shut up oh [ __ ] he's a clown in it
did you see that so defending because we
said it before the monster changed
that's so cool alright that should be it
oh Jesus
the guy does not like electricity or
wizards either one I don't know okay now
we can go here BIP yay and now and give
it a bit the damn sound effects they're
doing this game boom Shakalaka
Kazaam
it's kind of nice good audio in that
phone look good angle on that is that
bow dad you're a Buddhist you want that
boat and when I bought him
give me that money you want to get mad
about everybody not boarding a minibar
give it a better get anybody but I
smooth about it well they never close
the investigation okay I'm getting the
creeps now
well she doesn't have any different
relationship than I with them so I want
to ask her
you barely remember what happened what I
remember is that we played a stupid
half-baked prank that probably got
Hannah and Beth killed Hey I mean it's
not our fault they ran into the woods
yeah okay I've expected them to do a
dumb thing like that yeah I could anyone
boat a boat would add smell with our
boat
sorry I'm sorry so definitely they die
either way
I'm sure that's what they meant at least
from now on all the consequences are
oh my dick that's I don't care that's it
if I heard that I beat a be gone goddamn
it's one of those it's one of those huh
as far as I can tell I still have all
seven of my limbs but
I don't know I can hardly see anything
down here pushed a car it I'll jump down
obviously oh [ __ ] he's coming Iran Iran
Iraq moving it thanks for the help there
it is
why there's a card here when will it
stop but whatever would have smooth air
but I'm exactly the same girl please
move Jesus Christ this is such a creepy
place are we gonna die
are we gonna be the first one to die we
didn't even do with a Buddhist mother
Hey
[Music]
all right we did it
100% oh my god stop talking about sex
you've just told him what do we get it's
better be them [ __ ] oh my god what
was that Iran Iran Iraq why would she
make it why did I click twice oh oh
something's about to happen yep
Oh it's smelling nasty brace yourself
Bruce perhaps there's something over huh
no we can go up again this feels very
unsafe she should probably be going
first should we go left all right let's
check out right I think I saw something
yeah nothing creepy about this I don't
what is that
whoa that is not a good very bad another
clue here wow this place is like
historical holy Batcave oh gotta be
Native American right
oh we better because miners we're
getting there arts and crafts on now all
right twice
probably their sexual tension just
[ __ ] destroying the place this is
Christ okay we can do this we can make
it out I'd be running seriously this is
really creepy I'm not aiming for our
booty this is the game all right I'm not
doing it I swear we made it out I see
snow yes a little riot of heart what
electricity over there let's go there
then why did we go through here again
there's anyone No cool
me neither let's go this way I'm sure
there's something to the left that just
can't be bothered I don't want to do
like a hundred percent playthrough or
some [ __ ] I'll be okay Cap'n over here
sounds great
she can walk a little faster that'd be
cool oh yeah l1 and you walk past it
right so uh we became more romantic more
curious and just went up Matt went down
really interesting how that works
it's like every time oh my what
Wow what is she seeing alright he just
saw someone at the cabin
who someone else's their way where is he
how does she see that that was that was
too obvious what the [ __ ] was that
they already did that jump scare come on
what was that what was that that was so
awkward what was that I just smiled what
was that that was not up to quality but
everything else so far I should have cut
that [ __ ] out
come on okay well we're going to the
cabin the never ending route to the
mother hugging cabin sorry it's our one
does that I don't know why you think
like starter some [ __ ] we do it trying
to be like walk faster this part is kind
of boring me at the moment
right I think we're almost there it's
okay we'll make it oh there's the moose
oh Jesus mousse gel mascara out of
control I'll be winning that was scared
man come on man
I don't know why we're walking so
goddamn far to this other place but
better be worth it
oh I get it so we can [ __ ] it out sorry
I'm so sorry where it's the place to
live well I just thought the yeah
alright we can sign out didn't figure
you for the glass-half-empty type you
got a better idea
stand back debbie downer
hey Mike you've got something on your
face oh my god okay that's how it's
gonna be oh my god where did she go
she obviously just oh yes oh oh oh all
right all right
Sam hey what you want to help me get
this fire going well I would just get
into the bath with that Hardy are
already hard alright why do what you
want to take a bath so bad so weird
okay go ahead where you're gonna see if
there's hot water I guess mm-hmm don't
know but I got a feeling we're gonna
find out everything this is making
noises here oh why do we get in here
ooh creepy masks weird I never
understood the us why would anyone want
that in the house
yeah let's go put a pipe into boom can I
hear it go no it's never really clear
where you're supposed to go in this game
hi guys hi what is he doing down there
it bothers me so much those things are a
joke man we used to do it all the time
well Josh no hot water's kind of major
oversight don't you think yeah yeah you
just got to fire up the boiler it's in
the basement all right you guys see if
you can find the spirit board Chris
let's go find it it'll be like a
scavenger hunt okay
guess so rad
yep for a ride alone this is so weird
why are we doing this I don't understand
I don't trust this man
this guy is the worst host ever like
nothing is working
he didn't prepare [ __ ] and he makes us
do everything else it's like what are
you doing
such an [ __ ]
I hate him mmm stupid okay we're in the
basement
I gave Chris a NASA mission together
yeah I was thinking they could use some
alone time
they are very sweet together I wish they
just freaking get on with it already I
swear they just need like something to
bond over you know some sort of
traumatic event send them into each
others arms I mean at this rate they'll
be in the geriatric ward before Chris
makes a move what about those two huh I
don't like him I don't ship them I just
wanted to say what it really means a lot
to me that everyone came back this year
and you know that you came Sam I guess
since he's sincere we'll be sincere
whatever you need whenever we're all
gonna make it through this together yeah
well then you can try a little harder
Josh I'll just try it alone
how about that mm-hmm well what the [ __ ]
was that like I know how to use a
flashlight no getting tired of this
darkness please for the love of God how
big is this house what do we get
sorry to drag you down into the bowel
just give me some hot water and I'll be
super fine I mean I wouldn't want you
coming down here on your own you know
well it's definitely creepy down here
yep not a place to be on your own well
plus I wouldn't know where the [ __ ]
boiler is or how they work it cuz this
is not my [ __ ] house beep oh maybe I
do what is this a baseball bat it's the
ax nope baseball bat baseball bat in the
snow in the winter silly I mean we'd
come up in the summer and we would have
the best time the whole family was there
mom dad my sister's was some serious
competition out there on the big lawn I
don't know can't go back no reality
I want an [ __ ]
I'm not moving hey I swear to God I did
not move an inch what I said so intense
I'm not moving stop nice one
thank you thank you Josh okay first
things first we got to increase the
water pressure before we get the boiler
fire it out sounds kind of actually
pretty simple and do it
bap bap bap bap bap bap fat FFF
yes we could I almost missed it right
iran-iraq Oh what's happening yeah quit
it Josh Josh you have a you have a boner
Josh Jesus clients get off you're
disgusting
I'll prank that [ __ ]
don't
you
Yeah right no seriously
that seriously judge
yeah where did you the first point know
nothing regular about it
I'll check it out I'm a strong virgin
protagonist it's probably not anything
hey you know hey hey hey what the
[ __ ] ass
what oh my [ __ ] what Eddie not now are
you too scared my tits off
to keep out strangers fight improv why
would you do that was I not supposed to
take advantage of the opportunity thank
you
are you serious I'm ready to admit these
guys really love pranks huh that's
pretty pimpin I found my true calling
please tell me you're gonna take a vow
of silence
okay okay did you at least find the oh
here's our one-way ticket to the spirit
realm you know I've just been through
enough spooky for one night okay I see a
hot bath in my crystal ball all right by
the electricity they're seriously not
gonna get the electricity all right all
right all right Russ we're gonna end
that episode there hope you enjoy this
game is awesome I am really loving it
and I really really appreciate your
brothers living your support for this
series and I will see you as promised
tomorrow stay awesome press